I
hey i'm edmund tran and i'm joined by
Dan hi hey how you doing I'm pretty good
what are we doing today we are playing
the 3d realms anthology 3d realms is a
developer and publisher of a lot of old
school games they used to be known as a
pudgy and they pretty much pioneered the
idea of shareware was upon G apogee is
actually how it's pronounced incorrectly
so what have they done today what are
they doing today today they are
releasing new versions of their old
games you know they did a Shadow Warrior
and rise of the Triad yeah and yeah they
kind of just releasing the rolled back
catalog as they see fit so this came out
like last week that's right yeah ok so
what we're going to do is because there
are how many games in the pack 32 there
are 32 get easier so we're not going to
go through what going to try and go
through most of them but I'm going to
give you one minute on each game yep the
time you and will at the one-minute mark
will switch over or if you finish the
first level yep you'll move on or if we
die off we die ok sounds good so there's
gonna be a race to ok many games as you
can we're gonna pump one games whole
place all right ready set go ok first
game is alien carnage this was known as
Halloween Harry over here in Australia
for some reason I actually like the name
Halloween Harry better look at that old
school Apogee logo you're going to be
seeing a lot of that and a number of
different variations as well let's get
the engine where you're going to skip
all of the intros I definitely remember
playing this one as a kid you know you
just get those disks is full of like
demos and share with you exactly hey
them over and over again because that's
what you did it's a kid exactly uh one
sewers factory office block really
interesting names you have 30 seconds
day Oh No ok so Halloween Harry is
interesting because you can't jump you
just have this jetpack right but you
also have a flamethrower and they both
use the same fuel source so if you run
out of fuel you can't jump which means
you can actually get stuck pretty easily
it's rescued a damsel there it's very
jute newcomb except except not o slime
thing this come before or after Duke
Nukem ah good question i'm not sure i'm
thinking them in alphabetical order
which is probably not the best soldier
to be really really cool like old club
now we're in like sonic mode here going
through all these pipes know any what
the hell you're going I know I am I got
this I got this
oh oh and we gotta switch there you go I
get done that's more your mono that's
one minute okay I'm gonna pause it to
give you a bit a few more seconds it's
event all right now it's fine it's
hotter for it doesn't work it doesn't
work in these old games ok good it up
and I'll sign it again all right Arctic
adventures go all right episode 1 BAM we
gotta go I don't have time to wait I
don't think I've doctor no I definitely
played optica this is one of those old
school games with like a home wall TGA
graphic yeah oh no oh okay we're gonna
thanks like oh well that's all we got
out of there God beside I saw his name
on that Georgia Prasad is on a lot of
these actually a Chelsea balls of steel
famous for duke nukem yes yes so we're
gonna play the Duke Nukem balls of steel
table okay go okay go ma'am how did you
crazy yeah what what what get him ball
is so in vogue these days they went you
know I was testing this game I'm like a
pinball whatever bye got really into
work because I started like all this
stuff saw the flashing on the border
yeah it's cool i wrote a comer one big
like in these days yes specially yeah
there were pinball everything um i'm not
doing well at all here oh no we lost the
ball okay okay we're saving a lot of
time those wheels good yeah biomedis i
remember by bio menace this guy has an
amazing mustache that's basically the
only thing you need to pay attention to
you don't know good mustaches against
these guys no I know we're gonna go it's
pretty good so that might oh yeah he's a
seventies action star all over a lot of
these games start with messages that say
please don't upload this to a bulletin
board it's not the shareware version
it's actually the full version Yeah
right Ok Go Go Go yeah lastic because me
the cosmic the cosmic guy is it Cosmo
Cosmo it's not Cosmo ah ok there's a
little gore in this game again I just
really crazy I love the 80s cars yeah I
don't let you shooting smiley slime yep
exactly shotgun
it's like run away you can actually go
in the buildings as well like you just
go in here no link yeah yeah then you
get a grenade how do I throw that again
that's a enter Oh see the animation yeah
two step oh that was anticlimactic oh it
was skeleton now if you like this was
like five nights at Freddy's but if he
has gone exactly all right Blake stamp
Blake stone aliens of gold this is the
first Blake stone game and it's
basically shitty Wolfenstein so look
like a rebel speed of pilot right yeah
it looks like so yeah um so yeah we've
got three minutes what plenty of time
okay it's a good thing you must find the
red access card okay here we go I got
like my little hobby amanha there I can
really make him out from the background
really I just not good enough at least
you shoot me yeah I can't actually
sprint which is a shame do you have a
meal now that hurts that hurts do I have
what I love that as a little like rbg
start like yeah it actually tells you it
tells you who's shooting at you if you
get shot out so I'll get shot by this
guy he's like yeah yeah sector patrol oh
that's a lot of electricity is limited
in a minute boss it was in charge or
deactivating Barry on for one I it's a
charge yeah just let scientists they
actually shoot back at you so don't be
fooled by their you know lab coats the
train comes yeah as they teach you in
science school exactly uh a lot of these
sound effects seem like they're ripped
straight from commander keen no there
which is interesting but oh this is the
elevator was commanding was was not a
failure monsters it was God it was think
it was a pudgy yeah cuz I think if it's
not good but there's owns the license
now because right here right so they're
dead nay Allen get ready Blake for the
next game log off Blake oh wait Blake's
back in like star planet strike likes
back yeah so this goes from like
Wolfenstein graphics to rise of the
Triad graphics and if you look at the
Hat all look at that guy double da da he
hasn't warning graphic violence new
mission I love this by the way yeah
okay so Garrity Blake you must find the
fish and detonator and destroy the
security queue before the next level
okay oh yeah it definitely is very much
by the time yeah realistic and exactly
in look it's a bit darker as well as
that blogging effect it looks like the
rise in Pride this is what i thought it
was and think i'm pretty sure that's
exactly right you know we're gonna shame
gone now tell me a lot doctor less
brighton spacey yeah like um no lighting
attacks off your gun fires that Mecca
Hitler no it's a brain in a jar he's
always like every skin know exactly yeah
dude what that means nap then yeah and
it fills in as you go which is insane
like I think it's look at that oh yeah
it's like some line of sight yeah this
is like we do hello hello is that my dad
hey Dad he's fine I ran out of a
molestation I yes exactly yeah yes there
was some really advanced stuff you
probably don't need it like you know
doom had the automatic rest yeah and all
that's my mission stats that's all gonna
be able to see a pop-up attention yeah
all right next oh no Oh Blake sorry bike
you're out of here cosmos cosmic
adventure which is a really inventive
title look at him go yeah he's got
suction cup hands so he can jump up
walls and like go uh begin game I don't
know what that is two worst nightmare
whatever no was that thing I'd like
stuck he's got stud dollar room exactly
what if you have like them evil I don't
know he's sick in many ways because the
interesting thing about this is like
it's a normal platformer but then also
eww yeah but then you can drop bombs and
blow things up so he's like a little
cosmic terrorist of some kind but like a
really happy one this is ouch yeah
that's some health whoa there's a lot of
pickups at the top here and I'm looking
bother with getting them because we want
to try and get to a wall that I can
suction up yeah we want to see some
suction want to see some suction action
ok so i paid for dad suction action oh
no I got one a [ __ ] I got one HP that are
then waffles I can't even tell ok go
haha in a game article mwah mr. happy
while he's doing alright just look at
his face hey that's up [ __ ] yeah yeah
next ok alright like seven military are
you high score high score and all sort
of right man Fox is gonna come out to
our yeah right now okay what game is a
very serious back to story I think I
wrote playing this the most it's my most
vivid memory well he won the trouble
with tribbles and this was a really
ultimately yeah that was an old logo
factor that guy just looked like a very
symptoms like tight exactly hitting
buggy is ok let's go look at his arms
when he's walking this is he's he's got
the best day ahead of him yeah despite
this being an obviously call girl Ajah
game like the animation yelling
character is a lot more exactly you have
a smaller color palette you can no one
comes strawberry then oh god he's
running off to me that's right calm down
wow it is space like the blood is like
yeah there's no gravity let's escape
okay uh you just carry on so what's
funny about Crystal Caves is this game
is set in space and there are oxygen
generators around so I can shoot the
oxygen generator oh no the vacuum is
rushing in the kind of spiral you can't
know you can't okay next game do that
quit it didn't quit dark ages I'm not
familiar with our game no this is one
that I didn't actually play when I was
younger so let's find out what this is
all about again whoa what is that I
don't go he's looking x looks at me when
I turn okay if you like firing out ways
um I think it's brody from point break I
think like I'm shooting waves at people
look at that also is it is he just long
as it once at all I always one sec this
is just like a surfer bro like a massive
LSD yeah this looks like the Jill of the
jungle engine yeah yeah which
it controlled like us like jello the
jungle did so oh no get a little hot dog
okay let me get the key to the wizard 60
seconds let's go you're good you're good
looking for next to hit there we go hey
wizard good dog oh no we're inside no
let's dami long I'm struttin okay next
is that okay blah look at them squat
that's terrifying no but not know dan
let me exit the cave I care about high
scores ok so large events narrow Valley
it's got a remake reason this I believe
is the remake and this is actually made
by remedy which is insane you know they
want to thank Alan Wake Max Payne look
at my portrait look at that man I live
to ride I told my veins let's go snake
alley Wow cinnamon so what you was this
ah I wouldn't know okay already so you
can fire [ __ ] from your car you can uh
there we go nope nope all on the blue
car you see no [ __ ] you it's like mario
kart top down or like micro machine yeah
Michael machine yeah I can't remember if
that had pickups on art with its this
doesn't he just run people over there
I'm like don't tell Bailey wailing yeah
this is a you know the hardcore 90s
everything was there's like twisted
metal yeah Mad Max yeah not so coming
back yeah exactly I don't know what that
was I'm like it's all right click up
twenty percent white damage repair I
guess so I'm just more concerned with if
I'm coming last what's that wonder why
attend the waistline even though all
those avatars in Japanese
yeah I'm sure that's right next oh next
okay oh that's the slowest men you've
ever seen but look at those walks on
yeah let me out let me out I'm talking
with death rally really go to the cigar
please let me leave and to the show and
current dang yes god it's good thing i'm
suffering time for this yep thank you
that doing very well 95 96 more for
something more recent check out LMAO wow
so this is very releasing they just
shove that in there jus nukem one ah
this is cool act before he he went bad
when he was a wholesome young man I
don't know man is like you spend this
time picking up sodas and footballs and
televisions and like you know in
chickens is so you can there it is pick
up some flags for my football football
oh no dynamite and you can cook chicky
for sure but yeah that's right yeah this
is just like he's the OL American Hero
where we're gonna go down here I'm all
out of fried chicken and soon football I
picked up a balloon you collect balloon
I love another reason behind all these
ran with it but I mean you know every
game just had to have a whole lot of
pickups no matter what it was to get
that high school man you have to call
exactly is the score chasing games oh no
the lift fell down oh I shot soda can
back when things whether one sent one
yeah no parallax in the background
either it's just like one picture
machine Oh God Oh make it I'll free
radians everywhere yeah okay hang on
nearly there oh no I shot the soda can
again long time it's been running you
thinking yeah so you have to get this
generator and just kind of like blow it
up I'm gonna jump through anyway oh damn
it next yeah leave him on mark on all
these classics how many games left you
think I let's do a couple more we can do
a couple more okay i'm gonna do a math
rescue because it's so much fun all
right Matt rescue is it you're gonna
have to hell with all these hands but if
we're gonna be on time limit I guess
okay on the butterfly uh
puts difficulty yes this is very just
hanging it up careful okay Douglas my
god 1414 wait why is no Ronnie 1110 up
okay right again that way we died whoa i
guzzled hate ice cream they prefer
shells chris through four walls of ice
cream across onto gobs of ice cream in
brazil how many globs of ice six what's
a gorilla no no one possible and i love
it that's a--that's that's what you're
learning okay there you go both minus
nine is three good excellent speed for
this mine's good to cream the box five
scoops how many would live for meat for
Bam oh so good okay watch out the bottle
solid stole your thingamabob dead it's
gone that route okay terminal velocity
okay I want to end on either wacky
wheels yep or the dream one the dream
one yeah the one the kids in his pjs all
right look a nice crowd I mean monster
bash monster bash that's right here we
go mmm oh man this thanks alright so I
do beautiful second yes forsaken sixth
off here there was not a game called the
fury three three cubes how the clone of
this it was really really silly but um
yeah what I brought up load up load up
our target destroyed okay let's go eat
it nice you know what cool a bit me you
know it's cool you could like fly into
the clouds let's go up here you go to
Spain no you just kind of go into the
upper atmosphere so now we're up here so
it's really nice oh it's fun for me I
mean just kind of go back down again
that's a really girl well from trees may
be so ambitious new game I know right
well it has only in addition gone I
don't know all right let's okay next
until he won that game
okay so either wacky wheels and wants a
dash that's what I want okay cut assume
here monster bash where is it in it this
is a strange game where you play as a
guy in a slingshot who shot zombies and
rescued pets guy slingshot he's what did
you say a guy in a slingshot sorry using
a slingshot in pajamas they're gonna
face yeah pjs I was deeply interested Oh
No look at intricacies his arms like a
little better ah alright I just like
gore I actually can't skip this begin
game oh cuz guns a kid is cancer old
icons Oh No okay dizzy quick F time for
hints I don't need hence your oh [ __ ]
the cat no I'm shooting the lock BAM so
you save the animals you save the
animals it's a really nice game about
saving animals all right he's really
close yeah he doesn't ow cookies a
little kid and he did away my issue
these skulls and they're like glad these
backgrounds are intense I know i right
oh look there's a triple shot up here
you shoot these guys and their heads
come off okay because I show the head of
the same time didn't happen but I can't
believe this game is so gory and you're
playing as a toddler I know yeah kind of
reminds you of that bio- game except
probably more to stoke maybe she just
call you it and see what happens from
just like fall down a hole all right Oh
is the right ho ho no I don't wanna win
spiky I'm sorry Paul these chests look
at that got damaged yeah hardcore
destruction of fast pretty gotta get
back up I don't ow 400 monster bash like
it is it a ladder you never liked in
commander Cain it was all about finding
secret holes yeah well for some reason
ok it's good get skewered oh there's no
skew animation in fact is taking a very
minimal amount of damage yeah it's like
one my Hills Kong kid you're out you
need to go now kid yeah
Oh once the back didn't that all right
cool that was a lot of 3d rom game that
was a lot of 3d really what it wasn't
even all of them what do we miss out on
like Danny let's find out but I can exit
this game so we missed out on major
Stryker which was a vertical scrolling
schmuck it's not very good one monuments
of Mars it's this really strange
platforming game mystic towers is a
psychedelic trip and it kind of scared
me when I played it okay magnets are in
Pharaoh's tomb are two games in the same
series about come like Zuckerberg
pushing blocks and stuff yeah all
wrapped walk on go ahead and wrapped
what's in one Raptor Raptor is probably
the best mom ever ever that's a big call
as a lot of young shmups yeah you take
agrarian you can take your great using
your art types and they can go shove it
that's a big cool yeah peanut Browns
gonna like have some words with you I'm
sure he will dan maverick you loser here
we go oh you brought our sector way one
look at that takes a lot that's nice
look at explosions it's a pretty nice
looking like everybody one by today's
standards like I think 16-bit here are
like ages yeah exactly there's like
really nice shattered what's way that
the pc didn't have like 16-bit and 8-bit
they kind of just copied the style
that's right because that's what was
popular at the time oh no helicopters
[ __ ] cute let's fly into stuff ready
clothes load it ain't done yeah shields
down whoa epic you gotta count seen it
was crashing as well Paul Merrill oh
well that is the 3d realms and quality
now you for joining us so where can they
get it how much is it you can get on
steam it's about 25 30 bucks depending
on where your region good old games as
well a lot of these games were available
individually beforehand but this is the
first time they've been brought together
in one big pack Wow cool so for more on
that get a game spot I guess yeah until
next time bye
you